vous avez rendu des gâteaux pour tout le
monde oui il faut c'est un hameau parce
que il a fait la production ce matin il
a dit j'ai vous avez rendez des gâteaux
pour tout le monde oui gérant des
gâteaux avec julie à cagnes et julie les
filles de moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez tous que tout le monde ait
mangé ça tu dis est une saloperie de mon
régime des temps des temps d'attenté
moyen de cyril hanouna
non mais tu es bien c'est ma grand mère
qui les agressions c'est julie qui la
met série lentement mais sûrement mais
moi je le dis haut dans les yeux est ce
que ces gâteaux sont nés vraie rentrée à
l'est le magic qui se forme alors
[Musique]
c'est pas gentil nous nos mères nos
grands mères ont passé des heures et des
heures à faire ces gâteaux avec amour
avec la passion non je te connais tu es
un homme bon ganis grande jeune gâteau
je nourris dire une chose pareille
je vendais c'est un joli cadeau
on respecte on est en direct mais se
comporte bien avec enrico on a raté
mission d'angelina sans rigoler ya
juliette gréco qui vous avez gardé bien
tout cela vous manger des gâteaux moi je
vais manger ça suffit allez dans ok ok
prenez-en
[Rires]
eh ben tu mort dans le mien je jure
bazille juste vas-y je ne m'en rappelle
il va d'els van doren abidal doit aller
vu manger debout
ayité le loup ils sont un peu le point
[Rires]
allard a réécouté une bassine et
franchement ça ça sent la vue basse au
pied du poisson mort anonymes les très
beaux moments musicaux nous a envoyé la
vidéo de tapas y tarasov joli film le
message qui disait je veux absolument
privées cette bombe de rumba le
chroniqueur ces gros tarbes a donc j'ai
prévu de foie de morue et j'en ai vu
entre les gagnants
gd
[Applaudissements]
on verra deux gars moi j'aime bien
wellwood bah oui allez j'aime je le mets
en hockey aux papillons mâles mais bon
point trop n'en faut pas une raison pour
bien sa ligne
[Musique]